in the early hours of the morning a
truck containing human cargo drives
through an industrial estate but the
people inside did not survive the
journey
by early evening the lorry with 39
bodies still on board
was moved from where it had been parked
overnight so that those who so
tragically lost their lives can be
recovered we don't know who they are or
where they're from but how they got to
Essex is now the focus of an
international police inquiry the lorry
in the trailer will be moved to a secure
location it's he'll be docks so the
bodies can be recovered whilst
preserving the dignity of the victims
we're yet to identify them and must
manage this sensitively with their
families this investigation began
shortly after 2:00 a.m. the truck had
been parked outside a vacant industrial
unit on the outskirts of Gray's he
wasn't the police that were first
alerted it was the ambulance service
five ambulances were dispatched but when
they got here all of those on board were
already dead as forensic officers
carried out their methodical search of
the scene detectives were beginning to
piece together how the lorry got to the
water glade industrial park the police
were alerted shortly after 1:40 in the
morning the lorry had left Furyk at
around five past one but it had arrived
in Purfleet docks
shortly after 12:30 a.m. and it's
thought the container had traveled from
Zeebrugge er in Belgium where it was
before Zeebrugge er is still unclear
originally police believed it may have
come from Bulgaria because that's where
the truck is registered but the
authorities there say it hasn't been in
the country since 2017 the window of the
cab has Irish stickers and it's believed
many Irish trucks take on a Bulgarian
identity for tax reasons Sky News
understands that the driver is 25 year
old Moe Robinson from near Porter down
in County Armagh his Facebook page
contains images of what appears to be
the same lorry under investigation this
witness told Sky News and the police
that he saw the distinctive truck parked
at the same spot on Tuesday afternoon 10
hours before making its pickup at the
docks
possibly waiting for the
Fairey to arrive and to swap containers
what drove me to it was the unit itself
and made me remember it the cab looks
very expensive where that big chrome
exhaust and the paintwork when it is
unusual from being occur a company lorry
is more of a private okay yeah and was
there any sign of anybody at the lorry
at the time or inside I thought that
someone was a sleeping side because the
the curtains on the cab were pulled
round like the drivers do when they're
sleeping in their cabs the discovery of
the bodies and the launch of a murder
inquiry was briefly enough to interrupt
a brexit arguments with the commons
united in horror at the news the
perpetrators of that crime and indeed
all those who engage in similar activity
as we know that this trade is going on
Oh such traders in human beings should
be hunted down and brought to justice
can we just think for a moment of what
it must have been like for those thirty
nine people obviously in a desperate and
dangerous situation for their lives to
end suffocated to death in a container
this is an unbelievable human tragedy
that happened in our country at this
time there was appreciating to for the
emergency services dealing with the
aftermath the huge number of victims
involved suggests a smuggling operation
rather than random stowaways so even
though one man is currently being
questioned the police will be well aware
that there are likely to be other
suspects either in this country or in
mainland Europe in Woods Sky News Essex